los ojos de miles de seguidores se
posaban sobre la catedral de saint
gilles en edimburgo después de que más
de 26 mil personas visitarán el cuerpo
de la reina isabel segunda salió hacia
su próximo destino londres
un coche fúnebre transportó el ataúd al
aeropuerto de edimburgo en compañía de
su hija la princesa anna las lágrimas y
la emoción acompañaron a los seguidores
de la monarca mientras veían el vehículo
alejarse triste pero encantador la
extrañaremos terriblemente creo que todo
el mundo lo hará
tengo la sensación de que era amada por
todos aquí no sabía la cantidad de amor
que las personas le tenían en escocia me
está afectando
este ataque en homenaje es el himno
nacional y dos minutos de silencio en
marcaron el despegue del avión con los
restos de la monarca más longeva de
reunido el vuelo de aproximadamente una
hora terminó en un aeropuerto en el
oeste de londres
el aterrizaje fue presenciado por la
primera ministra del reino unido- listos
y el ministro de defensa ben wallace
entre otros en medio del silencio el
féretro fue trasladado a un coche
fúnebre encargado de llevar los restos
de la reina al palacio de buckingham la
residencia oficial de la monarca durante
sus 70 años en el trono
del aeropuerto al palacio el camino del
féretro estuvo acompañado por miles de
personas que se congregaron al lado y
lado de la carretera
innovación recibió la tau de la reina
cuando entraba al palacio de buckingham
desde allí el miércoles la fallecida
monarca será trasladada al westminster
hall donde permanecerá durante cuatro
días y en donde los londinenses y
visitantes podrán decirle adiós